Basically, I calculated the chain first and then I calculated all the other ones
where I couldn't count between the 0 in the first element because I'd already done that
and so it's just one list and write down a whole lot mixed--that one was straight.
So it was less than 2n for the combination ??? so it has to be Θ(n).
&gt;&gt;Okay. &gt;&gt;And then n-1 links to get the chain. &gt;&gt;Yup.
And then n-2 links to get all the rest. So that's a total of 2n-3 which is Θ(n). Right.
Right. Yeah. I guess that's kind of another way to think about it.
I mean in this case I guess it's kind of simple but one thing I'd like to--
a more complicated guess is like what happens when you add one more edge.
Like you have your combination lock and you add another edge you can add
two more nodes to kind of each edge and add two nodes
and so it's going to continue to grow literally.
Then you think about what you have if you have one node.
Yeah. I guess kind of the jump from the first node to the second node is—
Sorry from the first node to the second node is a little different
because you only had one edge but you know sort of
when you think of big theta and big O notation
you're dealing with bigger numbers like how it grows as it gets very large.
Because we're doing big theta you don't really have to think about
the base case of zero nodes or one node or two nodes.
&gt;&gt;Right. &gt;&gt;But if you think about in your case adding any node.
I'm going to add two more edges. So that's ???. Okay. Yes. Just. &gt;&gt;Yup.
Just part of the definition is like you know for all n greater than n₀, okay,
like you have fn is less than--like C₁gn or C₂gn and it's this part right here it's like--
as it gets bigger you can--you don't have to worry about those cases.
You don't have to worry about all the numbers that are less than some
and some maybe not but--
I mean for this one it's simple. It's kind of--it's pretty easy to think about.